je n'avais pas du tout prévu de parler
mais c'est pas grave me dit roger alors
quand j'écoute roger je me dis que avec
l'entrain qu'il donne on pourrait
presque le louer pour des soirées
mariages banquets républicains
ou alors il faudrait le clonés tels la
brebis dolly
en tout cas en tout cas nicolas sarkozy
vient de nommer roger délégué national à
la riposte est vu effectivement la
passion qu'il a lorsqu'il défend ses
convictions
lorsqu'il défend nos valeurs
républicaines et bien vous pouvez faire
une ovation à notre ami roger karoutchi
alors je me tourne aussi vers cette
nouvelle figure que vous ne connaissez
pas encore que vous êtes en train de
découvrir et que je trouve formidable je
n'ai entendu cette semaine j'ai léa
salamé c'est sur france inter j'ai
trouvé que tu te défends des lydia tel
le tigresse on va dire avec fermeté avec
conviction et surtout avec sincérité
il faut encourager les nouveaux visages
il faut encourager le sang neuf et vous
pouvez aussi encourager en
l'applaudissant lydia guirous cela
nouvelle porte parole des républicains
il y a aussi des nouveaux visages que je
voudrais que vous applaudissent ye qui
sont au premier rang il faudrait qu'il
se lève
camille camille bedin qui a fait un
travail formidable sur nanterre qui
travaille aux côtés de roger karoutchi
dans les hauts-de-seine
jérémy raid l'air dans le 16e
arrondissement de paris
alors olivier stirn tu n'es pas tout à
fait un nouveau visage mais tu sais
l'importance n'est pas effectivement ce
qui est écrit sur ta carte d'identité
mais la passion que tu mets toi aussi à
uvrer pour tes convictions l'ancien
ministre olivier stirn que vous pouvez
aussi applaudir
nicolas sarkozy va vous rejoindre
bientôt et bien sûr c'est celui que vous
attendez tous nous ne sommes que des
zakouski en attendant celui que vous
allez écouter entendre et qui est là
pour se battre qui est là pour se battre
pour promouvoir tout ce que nous avons
au coeur parce que la république je vous
le dis mes amis elle est en danger alors
je comprend effectivement que certains
se soit posé la question de savoir s'il
fallait changer d'appellation refonder
ou pas l'opposition républicaine
eh bien je fais partie de ceux qui sont
persuadés que les républicains c'est
très bien pourquoi je vous dis ça
d'abord parce que vous remarquerez une
chose c'est que ça les agace et c'est
qu'au parti socialiste ça les a un peu
titillé qu'il y à quelques intellectuels
bien pensants qui se sont aussi émus du
fait qu'on veuille désormais reparler de
république et faire ressurgir les
valeurs républicaines et bien j'estime
que c'était un bon signe et en attendant
vous de vous parler davantage de la
république vous pouvez aussi faire une
ovation à valérie pécresse
et dignement accompagné de philippe
goujon député-maire du xvème
arrondissement et valérie que vous
connaissez tous qui est une femme
formidable engagé qui connaît l'île de
france parker qui se bat et qui s'est
battu pour imposer une nouvelle
génération dans la région capitale et
qui va être notre porte drapeau
certes pour l'ensemble des élections
régionales partout en france mais
évidemment que nous allons avoir tous
besoin de votre soutien vous qui êtes
les meilleurs vecteurs de communication
qui soit n'écoutez pas trop les
journalistes les meilleurs porte parole
et les meilleurs vecteurs de
communication
ce n'est pas la presse c'est tout
simplement vous alors je vais bientôt
laisser la parole à valérie en attendant
effectivement nicolas sarkozy mais je
voulais juste vous dire une chose c'est
que la république oui j'estime qu'elle
est en danger et que regarder ce qui se
passe
observer nous sommes dans une société où
on ne respecte plus rien ou on agresse
une personne âgée pour lui voler 10
euros ou dans les guichets de
l'administration le ton monte pour rien
on est prêt à se battre aujourd'hui pour
prendre une place de parking à quelqu'un
d'autre
nous sommes dans une société qui est
grignotée tous les jours par l'incivisme
par le communautarisme par le
corporatisme et même par l'assistanat
qui crée un tel sentiment d'injustice
qu'il fini par entamer le vivre ensemble
alors vous avez d'un côté les
socialistes qui ont décidé de faire de
la république
une posture eh bien nous nous estimons
que puisque la république ne va plus de
soi puisque la république ne coule plus
de source
nous nous allons en faire un combat et
j'appelle effectivement chacun de nos
concitoyens
chacun des nouveaux membres et vous et
des nouveaux adhérents de cette nouvelle
formation politique qui renaît grâce à
la volonté nicolas sarkozy j'appelle
tous ceux qui veulent se battre
aujourd'hui pour se débarrasser de
françois hollande et de son aventure
insupportable
parce que regarder toutes les leçons de
morale que manuel valls que françois
hollande que cécile duflot nous avons
regardé tous les discours de vertu qui
nous assènent est en réalité on nous
avait défendu mon cher roger l'idée
qu'ils auraient une présidence normale
mais moi j'avais oublié que dans le
package
il y avait un premier ministre qui
aurait lui aussi dû être normal moi j'en
veux pas à manuel valls de devoir
voyager avec un avion privé pour des
raisons de sécurité en revanche je lui
en veux de prendre ses enfants à bord et
de considérer que tout cela est normal
parce que lui-même n'a même pas vu le
problème
donc vous voyez le décalage qui existe
aujourd'hui entre la parole et les actes
et c'est précisément ce décalage que les
français ne supportent plus alors si
vous êtes venus si nombreux ce matin un
samedi matin
vous auriez pu faire la grasse matinée
vous auriez pu regarder questions pour
un champion un télévision vous auriez pu
parfaire votre bronzage une matinée
d'été et bien non vous êtes là vous êtes
là parce que vous avez un engagement
civique impressionnant parce que vous
êtes je vous le dis même émouvant
émouvant parce que vous battez pour vos
convictions
vous battez pour vos valeurs vous avez
peur de rien alors une seule chose aux
et n'ayez pas peur assumer ce que vous
êtes
assumez votre fierté d'être de droite
ne vous laissez pas impressionner par
cette opinion publique qui vous explique
que dès que vous arborez un drapeau
français vous seriez facho ne vous
laissez jamais impressionné par cette
gauche qui essaie de vous dicter votre
conduite
vous êtes de droite vous êtes fier
d'être de droite vous êtes des
républicains et tous ensemble nous
allons nous battre pour faire ressurgir
les valeurs républicaines
merci beaucoup à vous